Hey youtubers, it's Charlie, so Hugh Jackman just dropped a bomb, said he's
only doing one more Wolverine movie, and
there's a whole bunch of
X-Men: Apocalypse, Deadpool news, so I'll try to explain
everything that's going on and what it means for the future of the X-Men franchise.
Let's just start with the Wolverine WTF
first 'cause most of probably grew up
with High Jackman as Wolverine.
Let me know how old you were when you
saw that first Bryan Singer film.
I you didn't see it this morning Hugh Jackman posted a picture this morning saying
'one more time'. Just to clarify, that means
one more Wolverine solo movie.
He's supposed to have a cameo in X-Men: Apocalypse but that movie's not
gonna center on him like Days of Future Past did.
And if you don't know what the schedule is X-Men: Apocalypse is coming out
May of next year, in 2016. The third Wolverine movie
is tentatively scheduled for March 2017, but
I'm expecting that to change. Really, I
think, after the initial shock wears off, you know,
no more hugh Jackman Wolverine pretty
soon, I think it's not that surprising.
Most actors leave a role way before this. It's funny and that it flies in the face
of what Robert Downey Jr. has said recently
about playing Iron Man. He said he's
totally gonna ride the wave into the shore,
which means he's gonna keep playing Iron
Man till people don't buy tickets for those
movies anymore,
which is essentially never. So at some point you will see a gray-haired Tony Stark.
I'll just go on record as saying Hugh Jackman is an amazing actor and even if
he doesn't play Wolverine any more
he will still continue to headline big blockbuster movies for a long time.
His next big movie is actually "Pan", he plays Blackbeard in "Pan" which is kind of a musical.
It's the same team that made "Les Mis"* so if you like Hugh Jackman doing that kinda                                                              *Les Misérables
stuff you'll totally enjoy this.
Those are probably the big 150 million
dollar movies he'll continue to make
after X-Men. Just to take a trip down
memory lane: the funny thing about Hugh Jackman's
time as Wolverine is that originally he wasn't supposed to be Wolverine.
When they were first putting the movie
together, when Bryan Singer was first putting that
original X-Men movie together, they wanted Russell Crowe.
He turned it down immediately. He was like 'no thanks', so they went down the list and the studio
really wanted Keanu Reeves or Gary Sinise which I know sounds totally weird.
They ended up picking Dougray Scott, this guy, who you probably don't recognize.
Then he ended up having to drop out of
the movie because he had a scheduling
conflict with the second Mission Impossible movie.
And then hugh Jackman finally made it on
the list because his
super duper best friend just happened to
be Russell Crowe superstar
who suggested him to Bryan Singer. The
studio wasn't super hot on the idea but
Bryan singer was the director, he's like
'I think this is a good idea, Russell
Crowe said he's awesome so let's give it a try'.
And the rest is history. But that is the
role that turned him into the mega
superstar Hugh Jackman that you see today.
So as much as it sucks that we're not gonna see any more Hugh Jackman Wolverine,
just remember, this is like 2017 we're talking about, when this Wolverine 3 is gonna come out.
In terms of stories for that third Wolverine movie, they haven't officially
announced anything but
Hugh Jackman did say that he wanted to
do an Old Man Logan story before the curtain closed.
I think right now that's the best theory. But I did put together a list of my
top 5 choices for stories that they should do.
I know a lot of people really hot on the
idea of death of Wolverine 'cause they just
did it in the comic books,
they kinda did that in the last Wolverine solo film, like where they took his powers and made him mortal.
That's what you see in a lot of these
Wolverine movies; it's they'll take like aspects
of these big Wolverine story arcs from the comics, they never do carbon copies of the comic book stories.
So top 5 Wolverine stories.We're we go, number 5: Weapon X.
This is more of a deep dip into the world of Weapon X, as they were creating Wolverine,
they were experimenting on him. Lots of
torture, really dark.
They did some of this during Wolverine
Origins, I mean let me show them creating Wolverine,
but there really weren't that many supporting characters, or the supporting
characters that they did have in the film
didn't feel like characters. So imagine a
movie
told more from their perspective. Think of it as more of a Frankenstein-Mary Shelley story
told with X-Men characters.
If you want to read it's Marvel Comics
Presents number 72 to 84.
Onto number 4: Wolverine alone.
This is like a small story inside of the
Dark Phoenix saga,
probably one of the most famous X-Men stories of all time. I know they just casted Sophie Turner as
the new Jean Grey so
I do think they're building towards a
Dark Phoenix movie, but I think by the
time they get there, by the time Sophie
Turner
is ready for that, Hugh Jackman will have
already makingvacated the role. So there's like
a small chance of this happening but
I really want to see him do it. The Hellfire Club has basically captured all the
X-Men and neutralized them
and Wolverine has the slice his way through each one of them to get his friends back.
But it's deep in the throes of Dark Phoenix. Jean Grey has already become the
Dark Phoenix in it and is going crazy all
over everyone.
So if do do this,  they'll just probably do like a Dark Phoenix movie and add this in like
a of couple scenes.
But I would like to see them cycle the Hellfire Club back into the movies just
because it's such an an interesting group of characters
Onto number 3: Wolverine Enemy of the State.
This would involve a Marvel/X-Men crossover so it's slightly unlikely.
I don't think we're gonna see a Marvel
crossover anytime soon.
But Wolverine gets mind controlled, loses
his shit goes, super dark,
and Nick Fury has to bring him in with the help of SHIELD.
The big antagonist in this story is The
Hand working with HYDRA.
The Hand is kinda like this evil group of ninjas that also shows up in a lot of Daredevil stories so
we can actually see them show up on the Daredevil TV series. But I know everyone
really wants a Dark Wolverine story at some point.
I don't know if they would wanna close
Hugh Jackman's run
as Wolverine on a really dark note but
it would be a really bold move.
Onto number 2, slightly more positive
choice: Kitty Pryde and Wolverine.
This from Chris Claremont's run, no surprise there,
probably one of the most famous X-Men
writers of all time. The story just
follows Wolverines adventures with
Kitty Pride in more of a parental child/senpai context.
Papa Wolverine takes young Kitty Pride
under his wing who
in this story is way darker then we've
seen in the movies.
Imagine like a Bad News Bears' version of Kitty Pride, just like really down and out on her luck.
Hugh Jackman is definitely at the right age
where he can totally pull off dad Wolverine.
Kitty Pride though I'm not so sure about
because Ellen Page might not be coming
back anytime soon.
they'd have to recast the role probably because I think when she came back in Days of Future Past
that was a one time thing. Even though
she does to look like a little girl, she
can still totally off little girl.
But I think the X-Men producers are trying to cycle in new younger versions of
the characters just so they have a little more longevit.
This is really like a perfect senpai Wolverine story, especially one that
involves a really strong female character
and it seems like the X-Men films, like Apocalypse for instance, are centering
more on the female characters.
Like X-Men: Apocalypse obviously gonna be about apocalypse, but mostly
its gonna center on Mystique's character
because obviously, you know, Jennifer Lawrence
biggest on the planet right now.
Kitty Pride also one of the best female X-Men characters of all time so
I really wanna see more Kitty Pride in the movies if possible.
And of course my number 1 pick for a Wolverine movie story: Old Man Logan.
Not only is it one of the best Wolverine stories of all time,
I think the thematically it's a good book
in for Hugh Jackman's run,
even though it's kinda dark. Wolverine gets my controlled,
like he does a couple of other times in the
comics, kills a whole bunch of his friends,
go super dark, like renounces the title of
Wolverine,
and ages into this future where the villains of the world had taken over.
The only reason I think they wouldn't do
story like this is because
this is like the "Fade to Black" (?) ending
where it's like 'how are we gonna fix this?'
and they fix that like in the next big team-up movie. If Wolverine kills a
bunch of his friends, kills a buch of the
X-Men,
how they're gonna explain that? Like, I mean, how they gonna do another X-Men franchise films
if they just recast all those young actors?
So they'd have to find a way around that, they'd have to have like a bunch of
redshirt X-Men characters for him to
kill. But it's such an amazing story did
I just I don't see them
not doing it at some point, whether or
not it happens with Hugh Jackman or some future actor.
So here's my big questions for you guys: what story from the comics do you want to see
them to you for Hugh Jackman's
last Wolverine solo film? Even though I
said they already adapted so of
death of Wolverine for the last
Wolverine film, I do think that they
could do a Death of Wolverine story and
it would totally work.
If you haven't read that story line in
the comic book, it gets into the idea of
multiple Wolverines after the death of
Wolverine, so there're number directions
they can take the Death of Wolverine story,
even if they do change a bunch of stuff from the comic book story.
I know a lot of you guys are asking about
the recent X-Men casting, they just cast
Jubilee for the movie.
I think, you know, like I said, they're
going with super young characters and
all the versions we've ever seen of Jubilee have always been really young teen girls.
Most of my memories of the character come from the 90's cartoon series
and she was kind of a silly character, like 'here some fireworks, here you go'
so I'll be interested to see what they change about that for the movies.
The funny thing about the Jubilee
character is, is that when they first
introduced her in the comics,
she was intended to replace Kitty Pryde
inside the Uncanny X-Men title
because Kitty Pryde had gone to Excalibur. So it's like Uncanny X-Men, one of the most popular
comic books of all time
lost one of its most popular characters
so they were like 'okay, we need to bring someone
back in to be the young teen girl,.
Thus Jubilee was created although she
never became as popular as Kitty Pride ever was.
There's also some really big Deadpool
news the just posted. Ryan Reynolds
posted this picture of himself doing
a very Burt Reynolds type-pose on top of a
bearskin rug, in front of a fireplace.
They also released some info about how
the movie is gonna tie in with the other
X-Men films, some I'm gonna do a separate Deadpool video for all that stuff
be sure to subscribe to get it.
I'll post it before Walking Dead's stuff, starts tomorrow. Seriously, big weekend
for bloody stuff, it's gonna be really fun.
While you guys wait for that to post you can click here to learn all about this
special Game of Thrones teaser that Jaime Lannister just dropped, it is really funny,
and you can click here to start learning
more about the Daredevil TV series, that's
actually coming in a couple weeks.
Thank you so much watching, let's all high-five, I'll see you guys tonight.